good evening from the Thomas & Mack
Center at the University of Nevada Las
Vegas I'm Chris Wallace of Fox News and
I welcome you to the third and final of
the 2016 presidential debates between
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton and
Donald J Trump this debate is sponsored
by the Commission on Presidential
Debates the Commission has designed the
format six roughly 15-minute segments
with two-minute answers to the first
question than open discussion for the
rest of each segment both campaigns have
agreed to those rules for the record I
decided the topics and the questions in
each topic none of those questions has
been shared with the Commission or the
two candidates the audience here in the
hall is promised to remain silent no
cheers boos or other interruptions so we
and you can focus on what the candidates
have to say no noise except right now as
we welcome the Democratic nominee for
president Secretary Clinton and the
Republican nominee for president mr.
Trott
Secretary Clinton mr. Trump welcome
let's get right to it the first topic is
the Supreme Court we you both talked
briefly about the court in the last
debate but I want to drill down on this
because the next president will almost
certainly have at least one appointment
and likely or possibly two or three
appointments which means that you will
in effect determine the balance of the
court for what could be the next quarter
century first of all where do you want
to see the court take the country and
secondly what's your view on how the
Constitution should be interpreted is do
the founders words mean what they say or
is it a living document to be a flaw
applied flexibly according to changing
circumstances in this segment Secretary
Clinton you go first you have two
minutes thank you very much Chris and
thanks to UNLV for hosting us you know I
think when we talk about the Supreme
Court it really raises the central issue
in this election namely what kind of
country are we going to be what kind of
opportunities will we provide for our
citizens what kind of rights will
Americans have and I feel strongly that
the Supreme Court needs to stand on the
side of the American people not on the
side of the powerful corporations and
the wealthy for me that means that we
need a Supreme Court that will stand up
on behalf of women's rights on behalf of
the rights of the LGBT community that
will stand up and say no to Citizens
United a decision that has undermined
the election system in our country
because of the way it permits dark
unaccountable money to come into our
electoral system I have major
disagreements with my opponent about
these issues and others that will be
before the Supreme Court but I feel that
at this point in our country's history
it is important that we not reverse
marriage equality that we not reverse
roe v wade that we stand up
citizens united we stand up for the
rights of people in the workplace that
we stand up and basically say the
Supreme Court should represent all of us
that's how I see the court and the kind
of people that I would be looking to
nominate to the court would be in the
great tradition of standing up to the
powerful standing up on behalf of our
rights as Americans and I look forward
to having that opportunity I would hope
that the Senate would do its job and
confirm the nominee that President Obama
has sent to them that's the way the
Constitution fundamentally should
operate the president nominates and then
the Senate advises and consents or not
but they go forward with the process
Secretary Clinton thank you mr. Trump
same question where do you want to see
the court take the country and how do
you believe the Constitution should be
interpreted well first of all it's great
to be with you and thank you everybody
the Supreme Court it's what it's all
about our country is so so it's just so
imperative that we have the right
justices something happened recently
where Justice Ginsburg made some very
very inappropriate statements toward me
and toward a tremendous number of people
many many millions of people that I
represent and she was forced to
apologize and apologize she did but
these were statements that should never
ever have been made
we need a Supreme Court that in my
opinion is going to uphold the Second
Amendment and all amendments but the
Second Amendment which is under absolute
siege
I believe if my opponent should win this
race which I truly don't think will
happen we will have a second Amendment
which will be a very very small replica
of what it is right now but I feel that
it's absolutely important that we uphold
because of the fact that it is under
such trauma I feel that the justices
that I am going to appoint and I've
named 20 of them the justices that I'm
going to a point will be pro-life they
will have a conservative bent
they will be protecting the Second
Amendment they are great scholars in all
cases and there are people of tremendous
respect they will interpret the
Constitution the way the founders wanted
it interpreted and I believe that's very
very important I don't think we should
have justices appointed that decide what
they want to hear it's all about the
constitution of and so important the
Constitution the way it was meant to be
and those are the people that I will
appoint mr. Drumm thank you we now have
about ten minutes for an open discussion
I want to focus on two issues that in
fact by the justices that you name could
end up changing the existing law of the
land first is one that you mentioned mr.
Trump and that is gun secretary clinton
you said last year let me quote the
supreme court is wrong on the second
amendment and now in fact in the 2008
Heller case the court ruled that there
is a constitutional right to bear arms
but a right that is reasonably limited
those were the words of the of the judge
Antonin Scalia who wrote the decision
what's wrong with that well first of all
I support the Second Amendment I lived
in Arkansas for 18 wonderful years I
represented upstate New York I
understand and respect the tradition of
gun ownership it goes back to the
founding of our country but I also
believe that there can be and must be
reasonable regulation because I support
the Second Amendment doesn't mean that I
want people who shouldn't have guns to
be able to threaten you kill you are
members of your family and so when I
think about what we need to do we have
33,000 people a year who die from guns I
think we need comprehensive background
checks need to close the online loophole
close the gun show loophole there's
other matters that I think are sensible
that are the kind of reforms that would
make a difference that
not in any way conflicting with the
Second Amendment you mentioned the
Heller decision and what I was saying
that you reference Chris was that I
disagreed with the way the court applied
the Second Amendment in that case
because what the District of Columbia
was trying to do was to protect toddlers
from guns and so they wanted people with
guns
to safely store them and the court
didn't accept that reasonable regulation
but they've accepted many others so I
see no conflict between saving people's
lives and defending the Second Amendment
mr. Trump in here the bipartisan open
debate coalition got billions of votes
on questions to ask here and this was in
fact one of the top questions that they
got how will you ensure the Second
Amendment is protected you just heard
secretary Clinton's answer does she
persuade you that while you may
difference agree on regulation that in
fact she supports a Second Amendment
right to bear arms well the DC versus
Heller decision was very strongly and
she was extremely angry about it I
watched I mean she was very very angry
when upheld and Justice Scalia was so
involved and it was a well crafted
decision but Hillary was extremely upset
extremely angry and people that believe
in the Second Amendment and believe in
it very strongly were very upset with
what she had to say let me let me bring
in Secretary Clinton were you extremely
upset well I was upset because
unfortunately dozens of toddlers injure
themselves even kill people with guns
because unfortunately not everyone who
has loaded guns in their homes take
appropriate precautions but there's no
doubt that I respect the Second
Amendment that I also believe there's an
individual right to bear arms that is
not in conflict with sensible
common-sense regulation and you know
look I understand that Donald's been
strongly supported by the NRA the gun
lobby's on his side they're running
millions of dollars of ads against me
and I regret that because what I would
like to see is for people to come
together
say of course we're going to protect and
defend the Second Amendment but we're
going to do it in a way that tries to
save some of these 33,000 lives that we
lose every year let me bring mr. Trump
back into that because in fact you
oppose any limits on assault weapons any
limits on high-capacity magazines you
support a National right-to-carry law
why sir
well let me just tell you before we go
any further in Chicago which has the
toughest gun laws in the United States
probably you could say by far they have
more gun violence than any other city so
we have the toughest laws and you have
tremendous gun violence I am a very
strong supporter of the Second Amendment
and I am I don't know if Hillary was
saying it in a sarcastic manner but I'm
very proud to have the endorsement of
the NRA and it's the earliest
endorsement they've ever given to
anybody who ran for president so I'm
very honored by all of that we are going
to appoint justices this is the best way
to help the Second Amendment we are
going to appoint justices that will feel
very strongly about the Second Amendment
that will not do damage to the Second
Amendment well let's pick up on another
issue which divides you and the Justice
is that whoever ends up winning this
election appoints could have a dramatic
effect that there and that's the issue
of abortion right mr. Trump you're
pro-life but I want to ask you
specifically do you want the court
including the justices that you will
name to overturn roe v wade which
includes in fact states a woman's right
to abortion well if that would happen
because I am pro-life and I will be
appointing pro-life judges I would think
that that will go back to the individual
states but I'm asking you specifically
would you like they overturned it it'll
go back to the states but what I'm
asking you sir is do you want to see the
court overturn you've just said you want
to see the court protect the Second
Amendment
do you want to see the court overturn
well if we put another two or perhaps
three justices on that's really what's
going to be had that's will happen and
that'll happen automatically in my
opinion because I am putting pro-life
and justices on the court I will say
this it
we'll go back to the states and the
states will then make a determination
Secretary Clinton I strongly support roe
v wade which guarantees a constitutional
right to a woman to make the most
intimate most difficult in many cases
decisions about her health care that one
can imagine and in this case it's not
only about roe v wade it is about what's
happening right now in America
so many states are putting very
stringent regulations on women that
block them from exercising that choice
to the extent that they are defunding
Planned Parenthood which of course
provides all kinds of cancer screenings
and other benefits for women in our
country Donald has said he's in favor of
defunding Planned Parenthood even
supported shutting the government down
to defund Planned Parenthood I will
defend Planned Parenthood I will defend
roe v wade and I will defend women's
rights to make their own healthcare
decisions right we have come too far to
have that turn back now and in indeed he
said women should be punished that there
should be some form of punishment for
women who obtain abortions and I could
just not be more opposed to that kind of
thinking I'm going to give you a chance
to respond but I want to ask you
secretary : I want to explore how far
you believe the right to abortion goes
you have been quoted as saying that the
fetus has no constitutional rights you
also voted against a ban on late term
partial birth abortions
why because roe v wade very clearly sets
out that there can be regulations on
abortion so long as the life and the
health of the mother are taken into
account and when I voted as a senator I
did not think that that was the case the
kinds of cases that fall at the end of
pregnancy are often the most
heartbreaking painful decisions for
families to make I have met with women
who have toward the end of their
pregnancy
the worst news one could get that their
health is in jeopardy if they continue
to carry to term or that something
terrible has happened or just been
discovered about the pregnancy I do not
think the United States government
should be stepping in and making those
most personal of decisions so you can
regulate if you are doing so with the
life and the health of the mother taken
into account mr. Trump your reaction and
particularly on this issue of late term
partial birth well I think it's terrible
if you go with what Hillary is saying in
the ninth month you can take the baby
and rip the baby out of the womb of the
mother just prior to the birth of the
baby now you can say that that's okay
and Hillary can say that that's okay but
it's not okay with me
because based on what she's saying and
based on where she's going and where
she's been you can take the baby and rip
the baby out of the womb in the ninth
month on the final day and that's not
acceptable well that is not what happens
in these cases and using that kind of
scare rhetoric is just terribly
unfortunate you should meet with some of
the women that I've met with women I've
known over the course of my life this is
one of the worst possible choices that
any woman and her family has to make and
I do not believe the government should
be making it you know I've had the great
honor of travelling across the world on
behalf of our country I've been to
countries where governments either
forced women to have abortions like they
used to do in China or forced women to
bear children like they used to do in
Romania and I can tell you the
government has no business in the
decisions that women make with their
families in accordance with their faith
with medical advice and I will stand up
for that right all right but just
briefly I want to move on but honestly
nobody has business doing what I just
said doing that as late as one or two or
three or four days prior to birth nobody
has that all right let's move on to the
subject of immigration and
there is almost no issue that separates
the two of you more than the issue of
immigration actually there are a lot of
issues and separate the two of you mr.
Trump you want to build a wall Secretary
Clinton you have offered no specific
plan for how you want to secure our
southern border mr. Trump you are
calling for major deportations Secretary
Clinton you say that within your first
hundred days as president you're going
to offer a package that includes a
pathway to citizenship the question
really is why are you right and your
opponent wrong mr. Trump you go first in
this segment you have two minutes well
first of all she wants to give amnesty
which is a disaster and very unfair to
all of the people the waiting in line
for many many years
we need strong borders in the audience
tonight we have four mothers of I mean
these are unbelievable people that I've
gotten to know over a period of years
whose children have been killed brutally
killed by people that came into the
country illegally you have thousands of
mothers and fathers and relatives all
over the country they're coming in
illegally drugs are pouring in through
the border we have no country if we have
no border Hillary wants to give amnesty
she wants to have open borders the
border secure as you know the Border
Patrol agent 16,500 plus ice last week
endorsed me first time they've ever
endorsed a candidate it means their job
is tougher but they know what's going on
they know it better than anybody they
want strong borders they feel we have to
have strong borders I was up in New
Hampshire the other day the biggest
complaint they have that's with all of
the problems going on in the world many
of the problems caused by Hillary
Clinton and by Barack Obama
all of the problems a single biggest
problem is heroin that pours across our
southern borders just pouring and
destroying their youth it's poisoning
the blood of their youth and plenty of
other people we have to have strong
borders we have to keep the drugs out of
our country we are right now we're
getting the drugs they're getting the
cash we need strong borders we need
absolute we cannot give amnesty now I
want to build the wall we need the wall
the border patrol ice they all want the
wall we stop the drugs we shore up the
border one of my first acts will be to
get all of the drug
all of the bad ones we have some bad bad
people in this country that have to go
out we're going to get them out we're
going to secure the border and once the
border is secured at a later date we'll
make a determination as to the rest but
we have some bad Umbra's here and we're
going to get them out
mr. trunk thank you same question to you
Secretary Clinton basically why are you
right mr. Trump is wrong well as he was
talking I was thinking about a young
girl I met here in Las Vegas
Carla who was very worried that her
parents might be deported because she
was born in this country but they were
not they work hard they do everything
they can to give her a good life and
you're right I don't want to rip
families apart I don't want to be
sending parents away from children I
don't want to see the deportation force
that Donald has talked about in action
in our country we have 11 million
undocumented people they have 4 million
American citizen children 15 million
people he said as recently as a few
weeks ago in Phoenix that every
undocumented person would be subject to
deportation now here's what that means
it means you would have to have a
massive law enforcement presence where
law enforcement officers would be going
school to school home to home business
to business rounding up people who are
undocumented and we would then have to
put them on trains on buses to get them
out of our country I think that is a an
idea that is not in keeping with who we
are as a nation I think it's an idea
that would rip our country apart I have
been for border security for years I
voted for border security in the United
States Senate and my comprehensive
immigration reform plan of course
includes border security but I want to
put our resources where I think they're
most needed getting rid of any violent
person anybody who should be deported
we should deport them when it comes to
the wall that Donald talks about
building he went to Mexico he had a
meeting with the Mexican president
didn't even raise it he choked
and then got into a Twitter war because
the Mexican president said we're not
paying for that wall so I think we are
both a nation of immigrants and we are a
nation of laws and that we can act
accordingly and that's why I'm
introducing comprehensive immigration
reform within the first hundred days
with a path to citizenship Thank You
Secretary Clinton I want to follow I
think it's I should respond to them
first of all I had a very good meeting
with the President of Mexico very nice
man we will be doing very much better
with Mexico on trade deals believe me
the NAFTA deal signed by her husband's
one of the worst deals ever made of any
kind signed by anybody it's a disaster
Hillary Clinton wanted the wall Hillary
Clinton fought for the wall in 2006
where there abouts now she never gets
anything done so naturally the wall
wasn't built but Hillary Clinton wanted
the wall well let me we already hunters
laws let me up and by the way no wait
I'd like to hear from what you'd like to
hear from I'd like to hear from
Secretary Clinton I voted for border
security and there are there are some
limited places where that was
appropriate there also is necessarily
going to be new technology and how best
to deploy that but it is clear when you
look at what donald has been proposing
he started his campaign bashing
immigrants calling Mexican immigrants
rapists and criminals and drug dealers
that he has a very different view about
what we should do to deal with
immigrants now what I am also arguing is
that bringing undocumented immigrants
out from the shadows putting them into
the formal economy will be good because
that employers can't exploit them and
undercut Americans wages and Donald
knows a lot about this he used
undocumented labor to build the Trump
Tower
he underpaid undocumented workers and
when they complained he basically said
what a lot of employers do you complain
I'll get you deported I want to get
everybody out of the shadows get the
economy working and not let employers
like Donald exploit undocumented workers
which hurts them but also hurts American
workers mr. Trump the President Obama
has moved millions of people out nobody
knows about it nobody talks about it but
under Obama millions of people have been
moved out of this country they've been
deported she is I want to say that but
that's what's happened and that's what's
happened big league as far as moving
these people out and moving we either
have a country or we don't we're a
country of laws we either have a border
or we don't now you can come back in and
you can become a citizen but it's very
unfair we have millions of people that
did it the right way they're online
they're waiting we're going to speed up
the process big-league because it's very
inefficient but they're online and
they're waiting to become citizens very
unfair that somebody runs across the
border becomes a citizen under her plan
you have open borders you would have a
disaster on trade and you will have a
disaster with your open borders what you
won't say is that President Obama has
deported millions and millions of people
just the way the darkling I want to
dream will not have open border that is
a rank mischaracterization secretary we
will have secure borders but we will
also have reform and this used to be a
bipartisan issue Ronald Reagan excuse me
immigration reform and George W Bush
supported it as well Secretary Clinton I
want to clear up your position on this
issue because in a speech you gave to a
Brazilian bank for which you were paid
$225,000 we've learned from the
WikiLeaks that you said this and I want
to quote my dream is a hemispheric
common market with open trade and open
borders so thank you yes Janet that's
the question please quiet everybody
is that your dream open borders well if
you went on to read the rest of the
sentence I was talking about energy you
know we trade more energy with our
neighbors than we trade with the rest of
the world combined and I do want us to
have a an electric grid an energy system
that crosses borders I think that will
be a great benefit to us but you are
very clearly quoting from WikiLeaks and
what's really important about WikiLeaks
is that the Russian government has
engaged in espionage
against Americans they have hacked
American websites American accounts and
private people of institutions then they
have given that information to WikiLeaks
for the purpose of putting it on the
Internet this has come from the highest
levels of the Russian government clearly
from Putin himself in an effort as
seventeen of our intelligence agencies
have confirmed to influence our election
so I actually think the most important
question of this evening Chris is
finally will Donald Trump admit and
condemn that the Russians are doing this
and make it clear that he will not have
the help of Putin in this election that
he rejects Russian espionage against
Americans which he actually encouraged
in the past those are the questions we
need answered we've never had anything
like this happen in any of our elections
before that was a great pivot of the
fact that she wants open borders okay
how did we get a hold on hold on oh no
oh wait hold on folks because we could
this is going to end up getting out of
control let's try to keep it quiet so
for the candidates and for the American
people just to finish her on the borders
yes she wants open borders people are
going to pour into our country people
are going to come in from Syria she
wants five hundred and fifty percent
more people than Barack Obama and he has
thousands and thousands of people they
have no idea where they come from and
you see we are going to stop radical
Islamic terrorism in this country she
won't even mention the words and neither
will President Obama so I just want to
tell you she wants open borders now we
can talk about Putin I don't know Putin
he said nice things about me if we got
along well that would be good if Russia
and the United States got along well and
went after Isis that would be good he
has no respect for her he has no respect
for our president and I'll tell you what
we're in very serious trouble because we
have a country with tremendous numbers
of nuclear warheads
1800 by the way where they expanded and
we didn't 1800 nuclear warheads and
she's playing chicken look from
everything I see has no respect for this
person
well that's because he'd rather have a
puppet as president and okok today no
pan it's pretty clear it's pretty clear
you won't admit now you have the
Russians have engaged in cyber attacks
against the United States of America
that you encouraged espionage against
our people that you are willing to spout
the Putin line sign up for his wish list
rake up NATO do whatever he wants to do
and that you continue to get help from
him because he has a very clear favorite
in this race so I think that this is
such an unprecedented situation we've
never had a foreign government trying to
interfere in our election we have 1717
intelligence agencies civilian and
military who have all concluded that
these espionage attacks these cyber
attacks come from the highest levels of
the Kremlin and they are designed to
influence our election I find that
deeply disturbing
I think it's Hugh has no idea whether
it's Russia China or anybody not no idea
I am quoting you have no idea 17 until
it do you doubt 17 our country has no
idea an agency's well yeah I gather by
doubt it Vladimir Putin then the
military and civilian intelligence
professionals who are sworn to protect
us I find that just absolutely I like
Putin because Putin has outsmarted her
at every step of the way excuse me
Newton hasn't [ __ ] her in Syria
that's more than I do get to ask some
questions yes and I would like to ask
you this direct question the top
national security officials of this
country do believe that Russia has been
behind these hacks even if you don't
know for sure whether they are do you
condemn any interference by
Russia in the American election by
Russia or anybody else you condemn their
interference of course I condemn of
course I can I don't know Putin I have
no idea timeouts I never met out and
this is not my best friend but if the
United States got along with Russia
wouldn't be so bad let me tell you Putin
has outsmarted her and Obama at every
single step of the way whether it's
Syria know you name it missiles take a
look at the start up that they signed
the Russians have said according to many
many reports I can't believe they
allowed us to do this they create
warheads and we can't the Russians can't
believe it she has been outsmarted by
Putin and all you have to do is look at
the Middle East they've taken over
we've spent six trillion dollars they've
taken over the Middle East
she has been outsmarted and outplayed
worse than anybody I've ever seen in any
government whatsoever we're a long way
away from their immigration but I'm
gonna let you finish this talk you got
about 45 seconds yeah and she always
will be I find it ironic that he's
raising nuclear weapons this is a person
who has been very Cavalier even casual
about the use of nuclear weapons he's
advocated more countries getting them
Japan Korea even Saudi Arabia he said
well if we have them why don't we use
them which i think is terrifying but
here's the deal the bottom line on
nuclear weapons is that when the
president gives the order it must be
followed there's about four minutes
between the order being given and the
people responsible for launching nuclear
weapons to do so and that's why 10
people who have had that awesome
responsibility have come out in an
unprecedented way said they would not
trust Donald Trump with the nuclear
codes or to have his finger on the
nuclear button I have 200 generals and
admirals 21 endorsing me 21
Congressional Medal of Honor recipients
as far as Japan and other countries we
are being ripped off by everybody in
there we're defending other countries we
are spending a fortune doing it they
have the bargain of the century
all I said is we have to renegotiate
these agreements because our country
cannot afford to defend Saudi Arabia
Japan Germany South Korea and many other
places we cannot continue to afford she
took that as selling nuclear weapons
look she's been proven to be a liar on
so many different ways this is just
another lie well I'm just quoting you
when there's no quote they're not going
to find a quote from nuclear nuclear
competition in Asia you said you know go
ahead enjoy yourselves folks that kind
and defend yourself well and defend
yourselves I didn't say nuclear and
defend yourself the United States has
kept the peace through our alliances
Donald wants to tear up our alliances I
think it makes the world safer and
frankly it makes the United States safer
I would work with our allies in Asia in
Europe in the Middle East and elsewhere
that's the only way we're going to go
we're going to we are going to move on
to the next topic which is the economy
and I hope we handle that as well as we
did immigration you also have very
different ideas about how to get the
economy growing faster Secretary Clinton
in your plan government plays a big role
you see more government spending more
entitlements more tax credits more tax
penalties mr. Trump you want to get
government out with lower taxes and less
regulation we're going to drill down
into this a little bit more but it isn't
this overview please explain to me why
you believe that your plan will create
more jobs and growth for this country
and your opponents plan will not in this
round you go for a secretary claim well
I think when the middle class thrives
America thrives and so my plan is based
on growing the economy giving
middle-class families many more
opportunities I want us to have the
biggest jobs program since World War two
jobs and infrastructure and advanced
manufacturing I think we can compete
with high wage countries and I believe
we should new jobs and clean energy not
only to fight climate change which is a
serious problem but to create new
opportunities and new businesses I
us to do more to help small business
that's where two-thirds of the new jobs
are going to come from I want us to
raise the national minimum wage because
people who live in poverty should not
who work full-time should not still be
in poverty and I sure do want to make
sure women get equal pay for the work we
do I feel strongly that we have to have
an education system that starts with
preschool and goes through college
that's why I want more technical
education in high schools and in
community colleges real apprenticeships
to prepare young people for the jobs of
the future
I want to make college debt-free and for
families making less than one hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars you
will not get a tuition bill from a
public college or university if the plan
that I worked on with Bernie Sanders is
enacted and we're going to work hard to
make sure that it is because we are
going to go where the money is most of
the gains in the last year's since the
Great Recession have gone to the very
top so we are going to have the wealthy
pay their fair share we're going to have
corporations make a contribution greater
than they are now to our country that is
a plan that has been analyzed by
independent experts which said that it
could produce 10 million new jobs by
contrast Donald's plan has been analyzed
to conclude it might lose three and a
half million jobs why because his whole
plan is to cut taxes to give the biggest
tax breaks ever to the wealthy and to
corporations adding twenty trillion
dollars to our debt and causing the kind
of dislocation that we have seen before
because it truly will be trickle-down
economics on steroids so the plan I have
I think will actually produce greater
opportunities the plan he has will cost
us jobs and possibly lead to another
Great Recession secretary thank you mr.
Trump why will your plan create more
jobs and growth and Secretary Clinton
well first of all before I start on my
plan her plan is going to raise taxes
and even double you taxes her tax plan
is a disaster and she can say all she
wants about college tuition and I'm a
big proponent we're going to do a lot of
things for college tuition but the rest
of the public is going to be paying for
it we will have a massive massive
tax increase under Hillary Clinton's
plan but I'd like to start off where we
left because when I said Japan and
Germany and I'm not to single them out
but South Korea there's a very rich
powerful countries Saudi Arabia nothing
but money
we protect Saudi Arabia why aren't they
paying she immediately when she heard
this I questioned it and I questioned
data weren't the NATO questions why
aren't they paying because they weren't
paying since I did this this was a year
ago all of a sudden they're paying and
I've been given a lot a lot of credit
for - all of a sudden they're starting
to pay up they have to pay up we're
protecting people they have to pay up
and I'm a big fan of NATO but they have
to pay up she comes out and said we love
our allies we think our allies are great
well it's awfully hard to get them to
pay up when you have somebody saying we
think how great they are we have to tell
Japan in a very nice way we have to tell
Germany all of these countries South
Korea we have to say you have to help us
out we have during his regime during
President Obama's regime we've doubled
our national debt we're up to 20
trillion dollars so my plan we're going
to renegotiate trade this we can have a
lot of free trade we're going to have
free trade more free trade that we have
right now we have horrible deals our
jobs are being taken out by the deal
that her husband signed NAFTA one of the
worst deals ever heard our jobs are
being sucked out of our economy you look
at all of the places that I just left
you go to Pennsylvania you go to Ohio
you go to Florida you go to any of them
you go upstate New York our jobs have
fled to Mexico and other places we're
bringing our jobs back I am going to
renegotiate NAFTA and if I can't make a
great deal then we're going to terminate
NAFTA and we're going to create new
deals we're going to have trade but
we're going to turn we're going to
terminate it we're going to make a great
trade deal and if we can't we're going
to do it we're going to go a separate
way because it has been a disaster we
are going to cut taxes massively we're
going to cut business taxes massively
they're going to start hiring people
we're going to bring the two and a half
trillion dollars that's offshore back
into the country we are going to start
the engine rolling again because right
now if our country is dying at 1% GDP
well let me translate that if I can
Chris because I you can't factor
he's going to advocate for the largest
tax cuts we've ever seen three times
more than the tax cuts under the Bush
administration I have said repeatedly
throughout this campaign I will not
raise taxes on anyone making $250,000 or
less I also will not add a penny to the
debt
I have costed out what I'm going to do
he will through his massive tax cuts add
20 trillion dollars to the debt well he
mentioned the debt we know how to get
control of the debt when my husband was
president we went from a 300 billion
dollar deficit to a 200 billion dollar
surplus and we were actually on the path
to eliminating the national debt when
President Obama came into office he
inherited the worst economic disaster
since the Great Depression he has cut
the deficit by two-thirds so yes one of
the ways you go after the debt one of
the ways you create jobs is by investing
in people so I do have investments
investments in new jobs investments in
education skill training and the
opportunities for people to get ahead
and stay ahead that's the kind of
approach deterrent that will work
cutting taxes on the wealthy we've tried
that so it has not worked the way that
it has been dr. Ecklund I want to I want
to pursue your plan because in many ways
it is similar to the Obama stimulus plan
in 2009 which has led to the slowest GDP
growth since 1949 correct thank you sir
you told me in July when we spoke that
the problem is that President Obama
didn't get to do enough in what he was
trying to do with this stimulus so is
your plan basically more even more of
the Obama stimulus well it's a
combination Chris and let me say that
when you inherit the level of economic
catastrophe that President Obama
inherited it was a real touch-and-go
situation I was in the Senate before I
became Secretary of State I've never
seen people as physically distraught as
the bush administration team was because
of
was happening to the economy I
personally believe that the steps that
President Obama took saved the economy
he doesn't get the credit he deserves
for taking some very hard positions but
it was a terrible recession so now we've
dug ourselves out of it we're standing
but we're not yet running so what I am
proposing is that we invest from the
middle out and the ground up not the top
down that is not going to work that's
why what I have put forward doesn't add
a penny to the debt but it is the kind
of approach that will enable more people
to take those new jobs higher paying
jobs we're beginning to see some
increase in incomes and we certainly
have had a long string of increasing
jobs we've got to do more to get the
whole economy moving and that's what I
believe I will be able to do mr. trunk
even conservative economists who have
looked at your plans say that the
numbers don't add up that your idea and
you've talked about 25 million jobs
created four percent over 10 years
growth is unrealistic and they say you
talk a lot about growing the energy
industry they say with oil prices as
well as they are right now that's
unrealistic as well your response so I
just left some high representatives of
India they're growing at 8% China is
growing at 7% and that for them is a
catastrophic lean low number we are
growing our last report came out and
it's right around the 1 percent level
and I think it's going down last week as
you know at the end of last week they
came out with an anemic jobs report a
terrible jobs report in fact I said is
that the last jobs report before the
election because of it is I should win
easily it was so bad the report was so
bad look our country is stagnant we've
lost our jobs we've lost our businesses
we're not making things anymore
relatively speaking our product is
pouring in from China pouring in from
Vietnam pouring in from all over the
world I've visited so many communities
this has been such an incredible
education for me Chris
gotten to know so many I've developed so
many friends over the last year and they
cry when they see what's happened I pass
factories that were thriving 20 25 years
ago and because of the bill that her
husband signed and she blessed a hundred
percent it is just horrible what's
happened to these people in these
communities now she can say that her
husband did well but boy did they suffer
as NAFTA kicked in because it didn't
really kick in very much but it kicked
in after they left boy did they suffer
that was one of the worst things that's
ever been signed by our country now she
wants to sign trans-pacific partnership
and she wants it she lied when she said
she didn't call it the gold standard in
one of the debates she totally lied she
did call it the gold standard and they
actually fact checked and they said I
was right everything I want to give you
a chance to briefly speak to that that I
want to give it to one city the mayor is
nestled on Oh care but go ahead well
briefly first let me let me say number
one when I saw the final agreement for
TPP I said I was against it it didn't
meet my tests I've had the same test
does it create jobs raise incomes and
further our national security I'm
against it now I'll be against it after
the election I'll be against it when I'm
president there's only one of us on this
stage who's actually shipped jobs to
Mexico because that's Donald he's Chip
jobs to 12 countries including Mexico
but he mentioned China and you know one
of the biggest problems we have with
China is the illegal dumping of steel
and aluminum into our markets I have
fought against that as a senator I've
stood up against it as Secretary of
State
Donald has bought Chinese steel and
aluminum in fact the Trump Hotel right
here in Las Vegas was made with Chinese
steel so he goes around with crocodile
tears about how terrible it is but he
has given jobs to Chinese steel workers
not American steel drum that's the time
that is just not going to work we're
going to pull the country together we're
going to have trade agreements that we
enforce that's why I'm going to have a
trade prosecutor for the first time in
history and we're going to enforce those
agreements and we're going to look for
businesses that was by buying American
products I asked a simple question she's
been doing this for 30 years why the
hell didn't you do it over the last
fifteen 20 years you were very much
involved excuse me
my turn you were very much involved in
every aspect of this country very much
and you do have experience I say the one
thing you have over me is experience but
it's bad experience because what you've
done has turned out badly for thirty
years you've been a position to help and
if you say that I used to yell or I use
something else I make it impossible for
me to do that I wouldn't mind the
problem is you talk but you don't get
anything done Hillary you don't just
like when you ran the State Department
six billion dollars was missing how do
you miss six billion dollars you ran the
State Department six billion dollars was
either stolen they don't know it's gone
six billion dollars if you become
president this country is going to be in
some mess believe me well first of all
what he just said about the State
Department is not only untrue it's been
debunked numerous times but I think it's
really an important issue he raised the
30 years of experience so let me just
talk briefly about that you know back in
the 1970s I work for the Children's
Defense Fund and I was taking on
discrimination against African American
kids and schools he was getting sued by
the Justice Department for racial
discrimination in his apartment
buildings in the 1980s I was working to
reform the schools in Arkansas he was
borrowing 14 million dollars from his
father to start his businesses in the
1990s I went to Beijing and I said
women's rights are human rights he
insulted a former Miss Universe Alisha
Machado called her an eating machine
and on the day when I was in the
Situation Room monitoring the raid that
brought Osama bin Laden to justice he
was hosting the Celebrity Apprentice so
I'm happy to compare my 30 years of
experience what I've done for this
country trying to help in every way I
could especially kids and families get
ahead and stay ahead with your 30 years
and I'll let the American people make
that decision well I think I did a much
better job I built a massive company a
great company some of the greatest
assets and then anywhere in the world
worth many many billions of dollars I
started with a 1 million dollar loan I
agree with that it's a 1 million dollar
loan but I built a phenomenal company
and if we could run our country the way
I've run my company we would have a
country that you would be so proud of
you would even be proud of it and
frankly when you look at her real record
take a look at Syria take a look at the
migration take a look at Libya take a
look at Iraq
she gave us Isis because her and Obama
created this huge vacuum and a small
group came out of that huge vacuum
because when they that we should have
never been in Iraq but once we were
there we should have never got out the
way they wanted to get out she gave us
Isis assures you are sitting there and
what happened is now Isis is in 32
countries and now I listen how she's
going to get rid of Isis she's going to
get rid of nobody alright we are going
to get to foreign hotspots in a few
moments but the next segment is fitness
to be President of the United States mr.
Trump at the last debate you said your
talk about grabbing women was just that
talk and that you've never actually done
it and since then as we all know 9 women
have come forward and said that you
either grope them or kiss them without
their consent why would so many
different women from so many different
circumstances over so many different
years why would they all in this last
couple of weeks make up you denied us
why would they all make up these stories
and since this is a question for both of
you
Secretary Clinton mr. Trump says what
your husband did and that you defended
was even worse mr. Trump you go first
well first of all the stories have been
largely debunked those people I don't
know those people I have a feeling how
they came I believe it was her campaign
that did it just like if you look at
what came out today on the clips where I
was wondering what happened with my
rally in Chicago and other rallies where
we had such violence she's the one in
Obama that caused the violence they
hired people they paid them $1,500
and they're on tape saying be violent
cause fights do bad things I would say
the only way because those stories are
all totally false I have to say that and
I didn't even apologize to my wife who's
sitting right here because I didn't do
anything I didn't know any of these
women I didn't see these women these
women the woman on the plane the woman I
think they want either Fame or her
campaign did it and I think it's her
campaign because what I saw what they
did which is a criminal act by the way
where they're telling people to go out
and start fistfights and start violence
and I'll tell you what in particular in
Chicago people were hurt and people
could have been killed in that riot and
that was now all on tape started by her
I believe Chris that she got these
people to step forward if it wasn't they
get there ten minutes of fame but they
were all totally it was all fiction it
was lies and it was fiction
well Secretary Clinton at the last
debate we heard Donald talking about
what he did to women and after that a
number of women have come forward saying
that's exactly what he did to them now
what was his response well he held a
number of big rallies where he said that
he could not possibly have done those
things to those women because they were
not attractive enough for me assault I
did not say that in fact he went on to
say her too impertinent sir her two
minutes but did not say that for two
minutes he went on to say look at her I
don't think so
about another woman he said that
wouldn't be my first choice
he attacked the woman reporter writing
the story called her disgusting as he is
called a number of women during this
campaign
Donald thinks belittling women makes him
bigger he goes after their dignity their
self-worth and I don't think there is a
woman anywhere who doesn't know what
that feels like
so we now know what
Donald thinks and what he says and how
he acts toward women that's who Donald
is I think it's really up to all of us
to demonstrate who we are and who our
country is and to stand up and be very
clear about what we expect from our next
president how we want to bring our
country together where we don't want to
have the kind of pitting of people one
against the other where instead we
celebrate our diversity we lift people
up and we make our country even greater
America is great because America is good
and it really is up to all of us to make
that true now and in the future and
particularly for our children and our
grandchildren mr. Trump nobody has more
respect for women than I do nobody
nobody has more ways everybody and
frankly those sewers have been largely
debunked and I really want to just talk
about something slightly different she
mentions this which is all fiction or
fictionalized probably or possibly
started by her and her very sleazy
campaign but I will tell you what is it
fictionalized or her emails where she
destroyed 33,000 emails criminally
criminally after getting a subpoena from
the United States Congress what happened
to the FBI I don't know we have a great
general four-star general today you read
it in all the papers going to
potentially serve five years in jail for
lying to the FBI one lie she's lied
hundreds of times to the people to
Congress and to the to the FBI he's
going to probably go to jail this is a
four-star general and she gets away with
it and she can run for the presidency of
the United States that's really what you
should be talking about not fiction
where somebody wants Fame or where they
come out of her
get campaign Secretary Clinton well
every time Donald has pushed on
something which is obviously
uncomfortable like what these women are
saying he immediately goes to denying
responsibility and it's not just about
women he never apologizes or says he's
sorry for anything so we know what he
has said and what he's done to women but
he also went after a disabled reporter
mocked and mimicked him on national
television
he went after mr. and mrs. Kahn the
parents of a young man who died serving
our country a gold star family because
of their religion
he went after John McCain a prisoner of
war said he prefers people who aren't
captured he went after a federal judge
born in Indiana
but who Donald said couldn't be trusted
to try the fraud and racketeering case
against Trump University because his
parents were Mexican so it's not one
thing this is a pattern a pattern of
divisive nough severe II dark and in
many ways dangerous vision of our
country where he incites violence where
he applauds people who are pushing and
pulling and punching at his rallies that
is not who America is and I hope that as
we move in the last weeks of this
campaign more and more people will
understand what's at stake in this
election it really does come down to
what kind of country we are going to
have so sad when she talks about
violence at my rallies and she caused
the violence that's on tape during a lot
the other things are false but honestly
I'd love to talk about getting rid of
Isis and I'd love to talk about other
things okay but those are the charges as
she knows there are fullness in this
bucket about fitness to be President
there's been a lot of developments over
the last ten days since the last debate
I'd like to ask you about about them
these are questions that the American
people have Secretary Clinton during
your 2009 Senate confirmation hearing
you
promised to avoid even the appearance of
a conflict of interest with your dealing
with the Clinton Foundation while you
were Secretary of State but email show
that donors got special access to you
those seeking grants for Haiti relief
were considered separately from non
donors and some of those donors caught
contract government contracts taxpayer
money can you really say that you kept
your pledge to that Senate committee and
why isn't what happened and what went on
between you and the Clinton Foundation
why isn't it what mr. Trump calls hate
apply well everything I did at Secretary
of State was in furtherance of our
country's interests and our values the
State Department has said that I think
that's been proven but I am happy
in fact I'm thrilled to talk about the
Clinton Foundation because it is a
world-renowned charity and I am so proud
of the work that it does you know I
could talk for the rest of the debate I
know I don't have the time to do that
but just briefly the Clinton Foundation
made it possible for 11 million people
around the world with hiv/aids to afford
treatment and that's about half of all
the people in the world who are getting
treatment in partnership with the
American Health Association we have made
environments and schools healthier for
Secretary Clinton healthier respectfully
this is this is an open discussion well
it isn't okay I understand in the
specific question went to paint it for
play do you want to very good work and
it's an ammonite
surprise and so Monday's like mr.
Johnston it's a criminal enterprise
Saudi Arabia giving twenty five million
dollars guitar all of these countries
you talk about women and women's rights
so these are people that push gaze off
business off buildings these are people
that kill women and treat women horribly
and yet you take their money so I'd like
to ask you right now why don't you give
back the money that you've taken from
certain countries that treat certain
groups of people so horribly why don't
you give back the money I think it would
be a great gesture well because she
takes a tremendous amount
of money and you take a look at the
people of Haiti I was in a little Haiti
the other day in Florida and I want to
tell you they hate the Clintons because
what's happened in Haiti with the
Clinton Foundation is a disgrace and you
know it and they know it
and everybody knows Secretary Clinton
very quickly we at the Clinton
Foundation spend 90% 90% of all the
money that is donated on behalf of
programs of people around the world and
in our own country I'm very proud of
that we have the highest rating from the
watchdog's that follow foundations and
I'd be happy to compare what we do with
the Trump Foundation which took money
from other people and bought a six foot
portrait of Donald I mean who does that
it just was astonishing but when it
comes to Haiti Haiti is the poorest
country in our hemisphere the earthquake
and the Hurricanes it has devastated
Haiti bill and I have been involved in
trying to help Haiti for many years the
Clinton Foundation raised thirty million
dollars to help Haiti after the
catastrophic earthquake and all of the
terrible problems the people there had
we've done things to help small
businesses agriculture and so much else
and we're going to keep working to help
Haiti because it's an important part of
the America I didn't want any of them
anymore I what I'd like to mention one
thing Trump Foundation small foundation
people contribute I contribute the money
goes a hundred percent 100 percent goes
to different charities including a lot
of military I don't get anything I don't
buy boats I don't buy planes what
happens when money goes wasn't some of
the money used to settle your lawsuit
sir no it was we put up the American
flag and that's it they put up the
American flag we fought for the right in
Palm Beach but put up the America there
was a penalty that was imposed by Palm
Beach County there was a pain a world
you're fine by the way the mud at
mar-a-lago it's a Fisher House where
they build houses the money that you're
talking about went to Fisher House where
they build houses for veterans and
disabled to get into one of ours there's
no way we can know whether any of that
is true because he hasn't released his
tax returns he is the first candidate
ever to run for
then in the last 40-plus years who has
not released his tax returns so
everything he says about charity or
anything else we can't prove it you can
look at our tax returns we've got them
all out there but what is really
troubling is that we learned in the last
debate he has not paid a penny in
federal income tax and we were talking
about immigrants a few minutes ago Chris
you know half of all immigrants
undocumented immigrants in our country
actually pay federal income tax so we
have undocumented immigrants in America
who are paying more federal income tax
than a billionaire why find let me just
tell you verse honesty
we're entitled because of the laws that
people like her pass to take massive
amounts of depreciation and other
charges that we do it and all of her
donors just about all of them I know
Buffett took hundreds of millions of
dollars
Soros George Soros took hundreds of
millions of dollars let me just explain
what no ever do most of her donors mr.
Trump done the same thing okay you know
what you should have the folks we read
you know Hillary what you should have
done you should have changed the law
when you were in United States Senate if
I don't like her that's because your
donors and your special interests are
doing the same thing as I do except even
more so you got to change a little bit
you won't change the law because you
taken so much money I mean I sat in my
apartment today in a very beautiful
hotel down the street known as played
with Chinese steel but I will tell you i
sat there i sat there watching ad after
ad after ad fall said all paid for by
your friends on Wall Street that gave so
much money because they know you're
going to protect them and frankly you
should have changed this loss if you
don't like what I did you should have
changed the law mr. Trump I want to ask
you about one last question in the in
this topic you have been warning at
rallies recently that this election is
rigged and that Hillary Clinton is in
the process of trying to steal it from
you
your running mate governor pence pledged
on Sunday that he and you his words will
absolutely accept the result of this
election today your daughter Ivanka
said the same thing I want to ask you
here on this stage tonight do you make
the same commitment in you absolutely
sir that you will absolutely accept the
result of this election I will look at
it at the time I'm not looking at
anything now I'll look at it at the time
what I've seen what I've seen is so bad
first of all the media is so dishonest
and so corrupt and the pylon is so
amazing the New York Times actually
wrote an article about it that they
don't even care it's so dishonest and
they've poisoned the minds of the voters
but unfortunately for them I think the
voters are seeing through it I think
they're going to see through it we'll
find out on November 8th but I think
they're gonna see better but Sir there's
a look excuse me because if you look at
your voter rolls you will see millions
of people that are registered to vote
Millions this isn't coming from me this
is coming from Pew report and other
places millions of people that are
registered to vote that shouldn't be
registered to vote so let me just give
you one other things I talked about the
corrupt media I talked about the
millions of people tell you one other
thing she shouldn't be allowed to run
it's called she's guilty of a very very
serious crime she should not be allowed
to run and just in that respect I say
it's rigged because she should never
trust she should never have been allowed
to run for the presidency based on what
she did with emails and so many other
things sir there is a tradition in this
country in fact one of the prize of this
country is the peaceful transition of
power and that no matter how hard what a
campaign is that at the end of the
campaign that the loser concedes to the
winner not saying that you're
necessarily going to be the loser or the
winter but the velu zerkin seeds to the
winner and that the country comes
together in part for the good of the
country are you saying you're not
prepared now two questions that I will
tell you at the time I'll keep you in
suspense well let me respond to that
because that's horrifying
you know every time Donald thinks things
you're not going in his direction he
claims whatever it is is rigged against
him the FBI conducted a year-long
investigation into my email
they concluded there was no case he said
the FBI was rigged
he lost the Iowa caucus he lost the
Wisconsin primary
he said the Republican primary was
rigged against him
then Trump University gets sued for
fraud and racketeering he claims the
court system and the federal judge is
rigged against him there was even a time
when he didn't get an Emmy for his TV
program three years in a row and he
started tweeting that the Emmys were
rigged shoulda gotten this this is a
mindset this is this is how Donald
thinks and it's funny but it's also
really troubling okay that is not the
way our democracy works we've been
around for 240 years we've had free and
fair elections we've accepted the
outcomes when we may not have liked them
and that is what must be expected of
anyone standing on a debate stage during
a general election you know President
Obama said the other day when you're
whining okay hold on close and hold on
folks it just shows you you're not up to
doing the job and let's you know let's
be clear about what he is saying and
what that means
he is denigrating he's talking down our
democracy and I for one am appalled that
somebody who is the nominee of one of
our two major parties would take that
kind of position I think what the FBI
did and what the Department of Justice
did including meeting with her husband
the Attorney General in the back of an
airplane on the tarmac in Arizona I
think it's disgraceful I think it's a
disgrace or I think we've never had a
situation so hot on Fox this this
doesn't do any good for anyone let's
please continue the debate and let's
move on to the subject of foreign
hotspots the Iraqi offensive to take
back Mosul has begun if they are
successful in pushing Isis out of that
city and out of all of Iraq the question
then becomes what happens the day after
and that's something that whichever
review ends up whoever of you ends up as
president is going to have to confront
will you put US troops into that vacuum
to make sure that Isis doesn't come back
or isn't replaced by something even
worse Secretary Clinton you go first in
this segment you have two minutes well I
am encouraged that there is an effort
led by the Iraqi army supported by
Kurdish forces and also given the help
and advice from the number of Special
Forces and other Americans on the ground
but I will not support putting American
soldiers into Iraq as an occupying force
I don't think that is in our interest
and I don't think that would be smart to
do in fact Chris I think that would be a
big red flag waving for Isis to
reconstitute itself the goal here is to
take back Mosul it's going to be a hard
fight I've got no illusions about that
and then continue to press into Syria to
begin to take back and move on Raqqa
which is the ISIS headquarters I am
hopeful that the hard work that American
military advisors have done will pay off
and that we will see a real really
successful military operation but we
know we've got lots of work to do Syria
will remain a hotbed of terrorism as
long as the Civil War aided and abetted
by the Iranians and the Russians
continue so I have said look we need to
keep our eye on Isis that's why I want
to have an intelligent surge that
protects us here at home why we have to
go after them from the air on the ground
online why we have to make sure here at
home we don't let terrorists buy weapons
if you're too dangerous to fly you're
too dangerous to buy a gun and I'm going
to continue to push for a no-fly zone
and safe havens within Syria not only to
help protect the Syrians and prevent the
constant outflow of refugees but to
frankly gain some leverage on both the
Syrian government and the Russians so
that perhaps we can have the kind of
serious negotiation necessary to bring
the conflict to an end and go forward on
a political trap mr. Trump same question
if we are able to push Isis out of Mosul
and out of Iraq
would you be willing to put US troops in
there to prevent their return or
something else let me tell you also so
said we had Mosul but when she left when
she took everybody out
we lost Mosul now we're fighting again
to get Mo's problem with Mosul and what
they wanted to do is they wanted to get
the leaders of Isis who they felt were
in Mosul about three months ago
I started reading that they want to get
the leaders and they're good they're
going to attack all so whatever happened
to the element of surprise okay we
announced we're going after most I've
been reading about going after Mosul now
for about how long is Italy three months
these people have all left they've all
left the element of surprise Douglas
MacArthur George Patton spinning in
their graves when they see the stupidity
of our country so we're now fighting for
muscle that we had all she had to do is
stay there now we're going in to get it
but you know who the big winner in Mosul
is going to be after we eventually get
it and the only reason they did it is
because she's running for the office of
president and they want to look tough
they want to look good he violated the
red line in the sand and he made so many
mistakes make all mistakes that's why we
have the great migration but she wanted
to look good for the election so they're
going in but who's gonna get Mel so
really will take Mosul eventually by the
way if you look at what's happening much
tougher than they thought much much
tougher much more dangerous going to be
more deaths than they thought but the
leaders that we wanted to get are all
gone because they're smart he said what
do we need this for so Mosul is going to
be a wonderful thing and Iran should
write us a letter of thank you just like
they really stupid
these stupidest deal of ulta a deal
that's going to give Iran absolutely
nuclear weapons Iran should write us yet
another letter saying thank you very
much because Iran as I said many years
ago Iran is taking over Iraq something
they've wanted to do forever but we've
made it so easy for them so we're now
going to take Mosul and you know who's
gonna be the beneficiary Iran boy are
they making I mean they are outsmarting
I look you're not there you might be
involved in that decision but you were
there when you took everybody out of
Mosul and out of Iraq you shouldn't have
been in Iraq but you did vote for it you
shouldn't have been in Iraq but once you
were in Iraq you should have never left
the way the point is your terminus is
going to be Iran well you know once
again Donald is implying that he didn't
support the invasion of Iraq I said it
was a mistake I've said that years ago
he has consistently denied what is a
very clear fact that before the invasion
he supported it and you know I just want
everybody to go google it Google Donald
Trump Iraq and you will see the dozens
of sources which verify that he was for
the invasion of Iraq and you can
actually hear the audio of him saying
that now why does that matter
well it matters because he has not told
the truth about that position I guess he
believes it makes him look better now to
contrast with me because I did vote for
it but what's really important here is
to understand all the interplay Mosul is
a Sunni city Mosul is on the border of
Syria and yes we do need to go after
Baghdad II and just like we went after
bin Laden while you were doing Celebrity
Apprentice and we brought him to justice
we need to go after the leadership but
we need to get rid of them get rid of
their fighters they're estimated several
thousand fighters in Mosul they've been
digging underground they've been
prepared to defend it's going to be
tough fighting but I think we can take
back Mosul and then we can move on into
Syria and take back Raqqa this is what
we have to do I'm I'm just amazed that
he seems to think that the Iraqi
government and our allies and everybody
else launched the attack on Mosul to
help me in this election but that's how
Donald thinks you know he always I mean
looking for some Chris we don't gain and
he has all the RAM is taking over Iraq
like the red is taking over
Bentley would if they surprised
Secretary Clinton it's an open
discussion he's gay now did it blaze mr.
Trump's face unfit and he proves it
every time you are the one that's in fit
you know WikiLeaks just actually came
out John Podesta said some horrible
things about you and boy was he right he
said some beauties and you know Bernie
Sanders he said you have bad judgment
you do and if you think that going into
Mosul after we let the world know we're
going in and all of the people that we
really wanted the leaders there all gone
if you think that was good
then you do now John Podesta said you
have terrible instincts Bernie Sanders
said you have bad judgment I agree with
both well you should ask Bernie Sanders
who he's supporting for president and he
has said which is a pain for me around
the country you are the most dangerous
person to run for president in the
modern history of America I think he's
right let's turn to Aleppo mr. Trump in
the last debate you were both asked
about the situation in the Syrian city
of Aleppo and I want to follow up on
that because you said several things in
that debate which were not true sir you
said that Aleppo has basically fallen in
fact there in fact there was a
catastrophe it is a catastrophe that
there are court have you seen it have
you seen it sir you seemed what's
happened to elect I might finish my work
okay so it hasn't fallen take a look at
it well there are a quarter of a million
people still living there and being
slaughtered it's right you also they are
being slaughtered yeah because of bad
decisions
if I may just finish here and you also
said that Isis that Syria and Russia are
busy fighting Isis in fact they have
been the ones who've been bombing and
shelling eastern Aleppo and they just
announced a humanitarian pause in effect
admitting that they have been bombing
and shelling Aleppo would you like to
clear that up well Aleppo is a disaster
it's a humanitarian nightmare but it has
fallen from the state from any
standpoint I mean what do you need a
signed document take a look at Aleppo it
is
so sad when you see what's happened and
a lot of this is because of Hillary
Clinton because what's happened is by
fighting Assad who turned out to be a
lot tougher than she thought
and now she's gonna say oh he loves
Assad she's just much tougher and much
smarter than her and Obama and everyone
thought he was gone two years ago three
years ago he lined he aligned with
Russia he now also aligned with Iran who
we made very powerful
he gave them a hundred and fifty billion
dollars back we give them 1.7 billion in
cash
I mean cash bundles of cash as big as a
stage we gave them 1.7 billion dollars
now they have lined he has aligned with
Russia and with Iran they don't want
Isis but they have other things because
we're backing we're backing rebels we
don't know who the rebels are we're
giving them lots of money lots of
everything we don't know who the rebels
are and when and if and it's not going
to happen because you have Russia and
you have Iran now but if they ever did
overthrow Assad you might end up with as
bad as a sadist he's a bad guy but you
may very well end up with worse than a
son if she did nothing would be in much
better shape and this is what's caused
the great migration where she's taken in
tens of thousands of Syrian refugees who
probably in many cases not probably who
are definitely in many cases Isis
aligned and we now have them in our
country and way do you see what is going
to be the great Trojan horse and way did
you see what happens in the coming years
lot's of luck Hillary thanks a lot for
doing a great job Secretary Clinton you
have talked about and in the last debate
and again today that you would impose a
no-fly zone to try to protect the people
of Aleppo and to stop the killing there
president obama has refused to do that
because he fears it's going to draw us
closer or deeper into the conflict and
General Joseph Dunford the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff says you
impose a no-fly zone chances are you're
going to get into a war his words with
Syria and and Russia so the question I
have is if you impose a no-fly zone
first of all how do you respond to their
concerns secondly if you impose a no-fly
zone and a Russian plane violates that
does President Clinton shoot that plane
down well Chris first of all I think a
no-fly zone could save lives and could
hasten the end of the conflict I am well
aware of the really legitimate concerns
that you have expressed from both the
president and the general this would not
be done just on the first day this would
take a lot of negotiation and would also
take making it clear to the Russians and
the Syrians that our purpose here was to
provide safe zones on the ground we've
had millions of people leave Syria and
those millions of people inside Syria
who've been dislocated so I think we
could strike a deal and make it very
clear to the Russians and the Syrians
that this was something that we believe
was in the best interests of the people
on the ground in Syria it would help us
with our fight against Isis but I want
to respond to what Donald said about
refugees he's made these claims
repeatedly I am NOT going to let anyone
into this country who is not vetted who
we do not have confidence in but I am
NOT going to slam the door on women and
children I that picture of that little
four-year-old boy in Aleppo with the
blood coming down his face while he sat
in an ambulance is haunting and so we
are going to do very careful thorough
vetting that does not solve our internal
challenges with Isis and our need to
stop radicalization to work with
American Muslim communities who are on
the front lines to identify and prevent
attacks in fact the killer of the dozens
of people at the nightclub in Orlando
the pulse nightclub was born in Queens
the same place Donald was born so let's
be clear about what the threat is and
how we are best going to be able to meet
it and yes some of that threat emanates
from over in Syria and Iraq and we've
got to keep fighting and I will defeat
Isis and some of it is we have to up our
game and be much smarter here I want to
get into our final sec
but I just have to it so ridiculous what
you she will defeat Isis we should have
never let Isis happen in the first place
and right now they're in 32 countries
you should have never wait one second
they had a cease fire
three weeks ago a cease fire United
States Russia and Syria in during the
ceasefire Russia took over vast swatches
of land and then they said we don't want
the ceasefire anymore we are so
outplayed on missiles on ceasefires they
are outplayed that she wasn't there I
assume she had nothing to do with it but
our country is so outplayed by cotan and
Assad and by the way and by Iran nobody
can believe how stupid our leadership is
mr. Secretary Clinton no we need to move
on to our final segment and that is the
national debt which has not been
discussed until tonight our national
debt is a share of the economy our GDP
is now 77 percent that's the highest
since just after World War two but the
nonpartisan committee for a responsible
federal budget says Secretary Clinton
under your plan debt would rise to 86
percent of GDP over the next ten years
mr. Trump under your plan they say would
rise to a hundred and five percent of
GDP over the next ten years question is
why are both of you ignoring this
problem mr. Trump you go first well I
say they're wrong because I'm going to
create tremendous jobs and we're
bringing GDP from really 1% which is
what it is now and if you got in it will
be less than zero but we're bringing it
from one percent up to four percent and
I actually think we can go higher than
four percent
I think you can go to five or six
percent and if we do you don't have to
bother asking your question because we
have a tremendous machine we will have
created a tremendous economic machine
once again to do that we're taking back
jobs we're not going to let our
companies be rated by other countries
where we lose all our jobs we don't make
our product anymore that's very sad but
I'm going to create a the kind of a
country that we were from the standpoint
of industry we used to be there we've
given it up
we've become very very sloppy we've had
people that are political hacks making
the biggest deals and there were bigger
than companies you take these big
companies these trade deals are far
bigger than these companies and yet we
don't use our great leaders many of whom
back me and many of whom back Hillary I
must say but we don't use those people
those are the people these are the
greatest negotiators in the world we
have the greatest business people in the
world we have to use them to negotiate
our trade deals we use political hacks
we use people that get the position
because they gave they made a campaign
contribution and they're dealing with
China and people that are very much
smarter than they are so we have to use
our great people but that being said we
will create an economic machine the
likes of which we haven't seen in many
decades and people Chris will again go
back to work and they'll make a lot of
money and we'll have companies that will
grow and expand and start from new
Secretary Clinton well first when I when
I hear Donald talk like that and know
that his slogan is make America great
again I wonder when he thought America
was great and before he rushes and says
you know before you and President Obama
were there I think it's important to
recognize that he has been criticizing
our government for decades you know back
in 1987 he took out a $100,000 ad in The
New York Times during the time when
President Reagan was president and
basically said exactly what he just said
now that we were the laughingstock of
the world he was criticizing President
Reagan this is the way Donald thinks
about himself puts himself into you know
the middle and says you know I alone can
fix it as he said on the convention
stage but if you look at the debt which
is the issue you asked about Chris I pay
for everything I'm proposing I do not
add a penny to the national debt I take
that very seriously because I do think
it's one of the issues we've got to come
to grips with so when I talk about how
we're going
pay for education how we're going to
invest in infrastructure how we're going
to get the cost of prescription drugs
down and a lot of the other issues that
people talk to me about all the time
I've made it very clear we are going
where the money is we are going to ask
the wealthy and corporations to pay
their fair share and there is no
evidence whatsoever that that will slow
down or diminish our growth in fact I
think just the opposite we'll have what
economists call middle outgrowth we've
got to get back to rebuilding the middle
class the families of America
that's where growth will come from
that's why I want to invest in you I
want to invest in your family and I
think that's the smartest way to grow
the economy to make the economy fairer
and we just have a big disagreement
about this it may be because of our
experiences you know he started off with
his dad as a millionaire when I start on
with my dad as a small businessman we've
heard this before I think it's you know
it's a difference that affects how we
see the world and what we want to do
with the economy time Thank You Hilary
could I just respond what not well no
because I'm Ronald Reagan very strongly
on trade I disagreed with him we should
have been much tougher and trade even
then I've been waiting for years no God
does it right and frankly now we're
going to do it right all right I the one
last area I want to get in to with you
in this debate is the fact that the
biggest driver of our debt is
entitlements which is 60 percent of all
federal spending now the committee for
federal responsible federal budget has
looked at both of your plans and they
say neither of you has a a serious plan
that is going to solve the fact that
that Medicare is going to run out of
money in the 2020s Social Security is
going to run out of money in the 2030s
and at that time recipients are going to
take huge cuts in their benefits so in
effect the final question I want to ask
you in this regard is and let me start
with you mr. Trump would president from
make a deal to save Medicare and Social
Security that included both tax
increases and benefit cuts in effect a
grand bargain on entitlements I'm
cutting taxes we're gonna grow the
economy it's gonna grow at a record rate
but that's not gonna help no I don't get
is going to totally help you and one
thing we have to do repeal and replace
the disaster known as Obamacare it's
destroying our country it's destroying
our businesses our small business and
our big businesses we have to repeal and
replace Obamacare you take a look at the
kind of numbers that that will cost us
in the year 17 it is a disaster
if we don't repeal and replace now it's
probably going to die of its own weight
but Obamacare has to go it's the
premiums are going up 60 70 80 % next
year they're going to go up over a
hundred percent and I'm really glad that
the premiums have started at least the
people see what's happening because she
wants to keep Obamacare and she wants to
make it even worse and it can't get any
worse bad health care at the most
expensive price we have to repeal and
replace Obamacare and Secretary Clinton
same question because at this point
Social Security and Medicare are going
to run out the trust funds are going to
run out of money will you as president
entertain will you consider a a grand
bargain a deal that includes both tax
increases and benefit cuts to try to
save both programs well Chris I am on
record as saying that we need to put
more money into Social Security trust
fund that's part of my commitment to
raise taxes on the wealthy my Social
Security payroll contribution will go up
as well Donald's assuming he can't
figure out how to get out of it but what
we want to do is to replenish the such
an emergency fund by making sure that we
have sufficient resources and that will
come from either raising the cap and or
finding other ways to get more money
into it I will not cut benefits
I want to enhance benefits for
low-income workers and for women who
have been disadvantaged by the current
Social Security system but what Donald
is proposing with these massive tax cuts
will result in a 20 trillion dollar
additional national debt that will have
dire consequences for Social Security
and Medicare and I'll say something
about the affordable care act which he
wants to repeal the Affordable Care
extended the solvency of the Medicare
trust fund so if he repeals it our
Medicare problem gets worse what we need
to do is go how's your disagrees
long-term health care drivers we've got
to get costs down increase value
emphasize wellness I have a plan for
doing that and I think that we will be
able to get entitlement spending under
control by with more resources as a
smarter decision this is the final time
probably to both of your delight that
you're going to be on the stage together
in this campaign I would like to end it
on a positive note that you had not
agreed to closing statements but it
seems to me in a funny way that might
make it more interesting because you
haven't prepared closing statements so
I'd like you each to take it we're going
to put a clock up a minute as the final
question in the final debate to tell the
American people why they should elect
you to be the next president this is
another new mini segment Secretary
Clinton it's your turn to go first
well I would like to say to everyone
watching tonight that I'm reaching out
to all Americans Democrats Republicans
and independents because we need
everybody to help make our country what
it should be to grow the economy to make
it fairer to make it work for everyone
we need your talents your skills your
commitment your energy your ambition you
know I've been privileged to see the
presidency up close and I know the
awesome responsibility of protecting our
country and the incredible opportunity
of working to try to make life better
for all of you I have made the cause of
Children and Families really my life's
work that's what my mission will be in
the presidency I will stand up for
families against powerful interests
against corporations I will do
everything that I can to make sure that
you have good jobs with rising incomes
that your kids have good education from
preschool through college I hope you
will give me a chance to serve as your
president Secretary Clinton thank you
mr. Truong she's raising the money from
the people she wants to control doesn't
work that way but when I started this
campaign I started it very strongly it's
called
make America great again
going to make America great we have a
depleted military it has to be helped
has to be fixed with the greatest people
on earth in our military we don't take
care of our veterans we take care of
illegal immigrants people that come into
the country illegally better than we
take care of our vets that can happen
our policemen and women are disrespected
we need law and order but we need
justice to our inner cities are a
disaster you get shot walking to the
store they have no education they have
no jobs I will do more for
african-americans and Latinos than she
can ever do in ten lifetimes all she's
done is talk to the african-americans
and to the Latinos but they get the vote
and then they come back they say we'll
see you in four years we are going to
make America strong again and we are
going to make America great again and it
has to start now we cannot take four
more years of Barack Obama and that's
what you get when you get her thank you
both Secretary Clinton ho hold on just a
moment folks Secretary Clinton mr. Trump
I want to thank you both for
participating in all three of these
debates that brings to an end this
year's debate sponsored by the
Commission on Presidential Debates we
want to thank the University of Nevada
Las Vegas and its students for having us
now the decision is up to you while
millions have already voted Election Day
November 8th is just 20 days away one
thing everyone here can agree on we hope
you will go vote it is one of the honors
and obligations of living in this great
country thank you and good night
that is the third and final debate you
see Chris Wallace there shaking hands
with Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
staying behind the podium interested to
see what happens there but this is an
evening with a lot of substance and a
lot of discussion of the topics that
have been in the news of late for her
the WikiLeaks documents for him
allegations that have been made against
him by many women so there's going to be
a lot to discuss and will be discussed
no single moment that I think will break
through and be the moment of the debate
but certainly a lot of back and forth
that will be memorable John almond your
thoughts well I agree with most of what
you just said there I think there is one
moment that will stand out to a lot of
people especially in the context of what
we've heard for the last week in which
Donald Trump has been repeatedly talking
about a rigged election saying that the
election was rigged and that they could
be stolen and that we needed to watch
certain polling places and so on the
idea that Donald Trump asked whether he
would accept the results of the election
answered and said he would not did not
refuse to see that corrected you are
correct that that will that will be that
will be a moment that will get a lot of
attention attention and it should and it
will be I think from the Trump campaigns
point of view kind of an unforced error
he had many good moments is probably his
best debate I thought she was I won't
say flawless but she kept him from
winning the debate simply by being so
strong but the moment you saw you
highlighted which which for some reason
blanked out of my mind for a moment
really will be the dominant there you
see Donald Trump in his family it's it's
storming off the stage but that moment
particularly because it's in conflict
with his campaign manager yes and his
vice presidential nominee and his
daughter who today said that he would
accept the results of the election you
know it is a core Democratic norm that
we accept the peaceful transcript sent
transfer power you can call for a
recount as Al Gore did you can challenge
results through the courts but in the
end the results of the election are the
results of the election you accept them
and you graciously step aside and I
think you see not already flag by every
major news organization in the country
and as I say it's against this context
he went on to say that millions of
people were on the rolls illegally that
there were dead people who would be
voting it was just the context of the
answer and the
faster than I think we'll get a lot of
attention again particularly the context
this week in which he's made rigged
elections so much a part of his rhetoric
as his poll numbers have slipped further
and further I think you're right mark
about Hillary Clinton I thought I
actually thought Donald Trump or the
first 30 minutes of the debate was
better than he's been in any of the
three debates he was calm and composed
and not full of invective but as the
debate started to get more emotional he
started to get more emotional and by and
large Hillary Clinton was calm composed
and strong throughout there you see
Donald Trump's running mate Mike Pence
working towards him this moment of Trump
saying the results he would necessarily
accept the results even within the base
of Donald Trump even the most hardcore
supporters I'm not certain there's even
a majority support for there and
certainly within the broader Republican
Party within the establishment within
the media that is a position that will
that will raise a lot of concern right
and I suspect to the extent he does
interviews in the coming days the extent
his campaign fields questions when
they'd like to be talking about his
strong moments in the debate
mostly what they'll be asked about is
what is up with Donald Trump's position
right on whether accepts the results or
not let's be clear you know he has his
campaign this week his campaign manager
and others tried repeatedly to say what
what he's really talking about is there
is the media bias that their perception
that he's getting a raw deal from the
media and every time they tried to do
that he on Twitter and elsewhere brought
it back to the possibility of fraud a
voter fraud which as we know through
academic studies in otherwise is an
extraordinarily rare occurrence in the
United States as people like Scott
Walker and other election officials
pointed out this week I think it's a
huge I mean I don't even call it
unforced error I think actually is what
he believes that's an interesting
question which is obviously he must have
been prepared during debate prep of
course to take the question yeah but I'm
not certain I'm speculating here I'm not
certain that that's the answer his
advisors urged in certain I'm certain
there are many advisers around him that
were horrified by that answer I think
there are probably some who had been
cheering him on but it does seem to me
to be what he actually believes that's
what I think and I think he may have
very well rejected a lot of his advisors
react because as you say you've had
Kellyanne Conway we've had his daughter
we've had others saying of course he
will accept the election results they
don't expect widespread fraud and then
here's Donald Trump saying something
totally different
in front of tens of millions of people
from a debate stage something we have
never seen in our lifetimes or
times prior to our lifetimes in a
presidential debate ever Hillary Clinton
still in the hall shaking hands with
supporters and other people in the
audience
Donald Trump has created a problem here
in terms of his campaign getting at
their message and a problem particularly
for Mike Pence who in a round of
interviews with Bloomberg and other news
organizations immediately before the
debate made it clear that issue was of
course they would accept the results
there were a lot of other things
discussed in the bait we should move on
to those I think Donald Trump more than
he has in any other debate he's being I
think roundly hailed for having long
stretches of calm on message performance
talked a lot about Hillary Clinton's
record right as part of the Washington
establishment and that those moments
very in line with the Kellyanne Conway
wing of his campaign that campaign major
who would like him to be talking about
change any more centrist message which
could be actually put together a
majority potentially I'll say I will
point out tonight on Twitter when Robert
constant leaving the debate all while
Laurie Clinton stays when Robert Costa
from the Washington Post pointed out a
disjuncture between the between how
Trump likes to talk and how Kellyanne
Conway would like him to talk
Kellyanne Conway retweeted that and
pointed an arrow at Kosta suggesting
that she was endorsing in some way
Kostas view that the old the old Trump
is at aa is at odds or the go to core
Trump the reflexive Trump is at odds
with his campaign manager she then as
publicly seem to have endorsed that so
we may see some some real discord coming
into the open I think in the days ahead
within Trump suit world I don't like
making predictions but I think there are
a lot of signs that we may see some real
fractures in Trump world over the days
ahead you see there the debate hall the
lidium Hillary Clinton no still there
shaky hands the final debate of this
campaign for her after after many both
against her Democratic opponents in here
the final of three defense against
Donald Trump Donald Trump has left the
debate hall and now
the room were in the spin room here
located near where the debate take place
is filling up with advisors for both
campaigns who've come here to tell the
media what they thought of the debate
and we're going to have analysis here
you're watching Bloomberg politics live
coverage postgame from the debate last
final president from here in Las Vegas
Jon Hamm and I and our colleagues will
be back with analysis some guests from
both campaigns and more and the most
tweeted moments don't forget about new
politics Bloomberg Television and
Twitter right after this
you
welcome back to Bloomberg television and
Twitter are calper to me here in the
spin room doing our postgame show at the
third and final presidential debate
we're joined now by General Michael
Flynn a big supporter of Donald Trump
general I want to ask you about what is
obviously to be the biggest headline out
of this debate Donald Trump saying on
stage that he would not necessarily
accept the results of the election his
campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway now on CNN we're told
has come out and said no Donald Trump
will accept the results of the election
what say you that this is a pretty big
pretty big thing for adoptive said no
presidential nominee has ever said
anything like that so will he or will he
not accept the results of the election I
mean I think he'll accept the results of
the election but I think what he's
talking about it and he didn't say you
know that's specifically what he talked
about was we just have to make sure that
our elections are run properly and that
they're done correctly and that we we
feel as Americans that that everything
that we're supposed to do during these
elections are done in the way that we
have always done our national election
so whatever the outcome is he'll accept
was he'll accept that outcome
all right so you realize your position
here is different from his position the
position you're offering it's not yeah
it's not different it's it's it's a it's
what he said he says let's wait to see
what happens at the election let's see
let's wait to see part of this also too
and he talked about it was look at the
just a barrage of anti of abuse that
he's gotten from the media I mean when
you look at at what he's had to put up
with withstand she's just in the last
week alone if not in the last you know
three or four months so that's when he
talks about what's going on in our
election process when you have sort of
this column which is you know whatever
you want to call the fifth column when
you have the media just going after one
candidate I mean it's almost 95 percent
of the media around this country that is
just attacking Donald Trump on a
constant basis that puts that poisons
the mind of the American public into
thinking that Jesus this guy that bad
sure I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure you
didn't mean to be suggesting the press
in this country are like Nazi
collaborators right I would say that the
press is definitely has a massive bias
against Donald Trump just to clear up
this point did he speak him precisely
when he said he'd have to wait and see
about whether he accept the results or
he said exactly the way she should have
said I think I think what you see on the
he'd stand on what he said and I
that what he what he said was
essentially that that the we just have
to wait to see what the what the outcome
is I mean what how the election process
goes the outcome of it whatever the
outcome of it is I mean we'll have a
peaceful election and all that sort of
stuff and he'll accept whatever the
outcome is I wouldn't I wouldn't read
much more into it okay I mean but but I
back to back to the rigged system that
he's been talking about part of this is
the media it is the absolutely the media
I mean you can't stand here and it would
you know your listeners and listeners
and only you can't stand there and say
that there's not a bias in the media
against Donald Trump there's absolutely
the media by against them biased against
someone who's running for the nomination
during the primaries you know I don't
know I have to I have to go back and
take a hard look at that do you accept
the premise the United States government
has that the wicked John Podesta's
emails were hacked by Russia do you
accept that premise I don't have I don't
know I just don't know what I've read in
the media you you've been briefed on
that no okay so you're not sure if it's
true or not
I don't know I just know what I what
I've heard the media right so whoever
whether it's Russia whether it's a
criminal organization I have read what I
what I know is what I read in the media
and what do you see in the WikiLeaks
documents that were system know the
whole thing about the about the you know
the whole issue about Russia it what
about the content of the emails that's
what I'm asking about the content what's
in those emails it was discussed tonight
do you think that voters might say I
wish more was discussed tonight what
didn't come up that you wish would I
just think the disparaging comments
about the American people that have been
stated by Hillary Clinton and her emails
and John Podesta and his email and and
just the emails than the exchanges of
information fact that they're not
they're not her emails their emails that
people who work for oh oh okay so is
that is that the climate that that she
has around her I mean the no and I wish
that there was more talked about was you
know it's the content of the information
I got that you know that they've been
hacked and all that I got all that I
mean that's you know that's that
happened and it's a and it's a criminal
act or it's an act of terrorism whatever
you want to describe it but the content
of the information is really what's also
an issue and
and and should be brought on and I think
the other thing too is just this issue
about that you know the 33,000 emails
the the numbers of things that she has
said that turned out to be lies so we
you can't deny that general I want to
clarify one thing you're you're one of
Donna tribes top national security
advisors right I help them out on
national security action and he's
received intelligence briefings right as
he's the nominee he's received a couple
right so again it's the contention of a
lot of people that he's been briefed on
this issue but he's not that he's not
been briefed on this issue not
everything the issue of the what you're
saying yeah and this business about
who's done what no not been briefed all
right thank you for you guys what we
haven't what we see in the media yeah
just wanted to clear that up thank you
very much for being here appreciate that
we're going to throw out to our
colleague Megan Murphy who is outside
the debate hall so she can give her as
her thoughts on what happened tonight
and do a couple of informative
interviews Megan thanks John all night
our partners at Twitter have been using
their abacuses to map the top Tweedy
moments of the night and we have them
right now tonight the moment that got
the most tweets came around 9:50 7:00
p.m. Eastern when Hillary Clinton went
after Donald Trump's past treatment of
women take a look at a listen he held a
number of big rallies where he said that
he could not possibly have done those
things to those women because they were
not attractive enough for identity
assault I did not say that the rose up
for top tweeted moments of the debate
were when Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton had an exchange about Aleppo and
also Trump defending his statements
about what's going on in Syria and also
when Trump gave his much awaited
wait-and-see answer on whether he would
accept the outcome of the election
telling us he'd keep us in suspense
turns out on that last one his running
mate Mike Pence gave our Bloomberg
politics college Kevin strahle a pretty
different on that answer on that
question interview just moments before
the debate began take a listen well
Donald Trump made it clear in his first
debate and I've made it clear that will
accept the will of the American people
but I think Donald Trump's gonna win we
got a brand new poll out today from
investors business daily that that has
this up a percentage point I see
tremendous momentum all across the
country let's put up a line graph of
Twitter traffic throughout the debate
we've been tracking this all night the
highest peak of Twitter chatter at 9:57
p.m. Eastern was about the women
discussion clip we just saw meanwhile
the top three issues that Twitter users
discussed over the past 90 minutes were
foreign affairs the economy and
reproductive rights I'm joined now by
Bloomberg politics reporter Steve EC
know Steve there's no question that does
John Holliman said early in the night
the big takeaway moment is going to be
Donald Trump saying he would not clarify
whether he will accept the results of
his election he said it not once but
twice he said he would keep us in
suspense and Hillary Clinton saying
calling it in effect horrifying that he
would have that stance that it was a
threat to democracy Chris Wallace or
Mondays at the end of the evening how
important each of our votes are do you
think this is damaging for his candidacy
and do you think it's whipping up
concern over something that American
voters will see as fundamental which is
the integrity of our voting system
Donald Trump has been saying this for a
long time on the campaign trail it's
been a little too soon to see exactly
whether or not this will affect him this
particular statement will we will wait
and see but he's been talking about this
for a while we've seen it rally his base
before I think the one thing to take
away from this night is neither
candidate really made their case about
why they were so going to be president
tonight Hillary did a little bit more
than Donald Trump but it was it was much
more about why the other person
shouldn't be president and it was a
back-and-forth the time it was like a
pivot contest where there would be a
question and one perfect person would
pivot to an attack and then the next
person would take that attack and pivot
to it a completely different subject and
I think that it's important to note that
one of the moments that Hillary Clinton
is the strongest was on that women issue
partially because she attacked Donald
Trump but then she pivot and she said
we're better than this and she gave this
long speech about how the country needs
to stand up because they were they were
better than this and I thought that was
her strongest moment at night because of
a sudden she cast a vision she wasn't
just attacking Trump yeah you know she
was more riled she was more personal and
it is like that her team and her self
decided to take on as an emotional issue
not just women but partial-birth
abortion children's rights a lot of the
things that she's talking about in
effect mark halpern and john holliman
have joel Benison hillary clinton's
pollster with them right now in the spin
room Megan thank you we're here with
Joel Benenson strategist raillery
Clinton I want to talk to you about the
thing that's obviously getting the most
attention Donald Trump saying that he
would necessarily accept the results
election twoness wants to see his aides
are sort of walking that back a little
bit is it okay at any level as far as
you're concerned for him to say hey
let's see what happens I'm inclined to
accept them in effect but let's see what
happens no it's not okay I think we've
got a you know a reason why the rest of
the world looks to us is the greatest
democracy on earth the one exception
we've had orderly transitions after
every presidential election I think
you've got Republicans around the
country who were appalled by what he's
saying but they've been appalled by a
lot of things in his campaign I think
tonight
was the the clearest win of the three I
think Hillary Clinton's won all three
debates I thought this was the most
lopsided and I think that you know him
him saying that he'll see what happens
is just outraged that maybe that will
hurt him with voters do you think and if
so why yeah I do because I think look
the American people know this is the
greatest democracy in history this isn't
a mystery to them they're not looking
for us to go to war over elections with
each other and I mean that
metaphorically please but you know I I
think they you know for voters they've
experienced this over and over again
they've experienced voting they've
experienced winning being on the winning
side being on the losing side and the
great thing about our democracy when it
works at its best is that we pick up the
pieces and we go to work together and we
make a difference for people and I think
that's why this was so lopsided Hillary
Clinton tonight was the only person on
that stage who laid out a vision of what
kind of country we she thinks we are and
what kind of country we want to be and
drew a very strong sharp contrast around
the value side of that argument the
economic side and how we keep the
country safe Joel if you remember back
in the first debate Donald Trump came
out very strong in that first half an
hour a lot of people talked about how
strong he wasn't then he sort of unravel
doesn't the debate went on tonight he
came out very I thought very calm a
calmer Donald Donald Trump for the first
30 minutes he's got a different look
from any Donald Trump that we've seen
over the last three debates now again
the last hour was slightly different but
just talk about that first hour when
Trump came out was that a Donald Trump
you expected to see the first 30 minutes
or so
you know I'm in the minority on this
I've expected to see that in all three
what would you know hasn't totally
surprised me now at the third one is
that he can't do this for 90 minutes he
becomes unhinged at some point during a
90 minute debate during which he only
has to talk about 40 minutes that to me
becomes a part of that the temperamental
unfitness that we've been talking about
so I think during the first 30 minutes I
thought he was trying to keep it very
cool stay very calm
I don't know in what particular set them
off but what we know is it doesn't take
much to set him off and that's one of
the reasons why he shouldn't be
President of the United States
we knew the troubles going to go after
her on the question of open borders and
take that piece out of the WikiLeaks
leaks and go and try to make a case of
that tonight he did of course first time
we talked about immigration in any of
the three debates so how do you think
that that exchange played I thought
we've talked about immigration before we
certainly talked about him building a
wall and and having a deportation force
before it gets come up maybe it wasn't
as full of section I mean it was a full
topic that's what I meant
look I think it played very well
Americans know we are a nation of
immigrants look I'm my grandparents came
from another country you know I'm
obviously not you know a recent young
person here I've been here for a few
decades I think most of people know we
came from different places and one of
the great things about America is that
we figure out how to make it work for
ourselves is it always easy of course
not and I don't think Hillary Clinton
would say that it's always easy but it
is who we are as a people and when you
start pitting people against each other
and you start calling out an American
judge because of his Mexican heritage
that's divisive it's not just divisive I
think most voters were coyle at that and
they say that's not how I raise my kids
that's not who I think the charge
against heard though in the charge he's
making is that she has a more and more
much more liberal attitude towards
immigration than the one that she even
espouses and debate so how do you answer
the charge that there has been something
revealed in these documents that shows
that Hillary Clinton in fact once more a
much more liberal immigration system
than she's willing to admit I don't
think that's accurate I think she's been
consistent the immigration plan she
fully advocates comprehensive
immigration reform just as Republicans
and Democrats have for several decades
now and it's it's pretty much intact we
have to do things to secure a border we
have to create a path to citizenship for
undocumented workers who've been living
here undocumented immigrants have been
living here working here paying their
taxes have a period by which they can go
through a path to citizenship and where
there are violent criminals apply the
resources to deport those immigrants but
not break up families not send people
back who have been living here I think
one of the great moments in the debate
tonight frankly was when she pointed out
that they were undocumented immigrants
who were paying more in federal income
taxes
then Donald Trump is including money
some of which goes for border security
as it turns out when WikiLeaks came up
she wanted to talk about the Russians
hacking into John Ziemann
John Podesta's emails Trump want to talk
about some of the content of the emails
do you think the American people care
about the Russian angle more than they
care about the content or they care
about both I think the American people
care most about their own lives I think
they care more about the fact that
Russia might be meddling in election I
think the other related piece to that
which I think she drove home pretty well
tonight is the fact that we've got
Donald Trump who doesn't want to believe
what 17 telogen say j'en sees in this
country have said he wants to believe
Russia I mean that's just unheard of do
you as we go forward here you all are
feeling pretty good about after tonight
and in general Ares do you sit in fear
or concern that there could be more
WikiLeaks disclosures between now and
Election Day you know I think I always
say that this election is about their
lives first and foremost
and the future you know future as
President Clinton once said not the past
I think voters heard tonight one
candidate during the course of that
debate who was talking about their lives
that we have to invest in the American
people I actually think that's what
they're going to be focused on over
these last 19 days if they haven't made
up their minds after tonight and I think
we're seeing a shrinking pool of people
that are open to this and I think for
Donald Trump the challenges in none of
these three debates has he reached out
beyond his base he just doesn't do it
Hillary Clinton tonight she said it I'm
going to be a president for all
Americans who didn't support me if you
did support me I'm going to be fighting
for you Joel Benenson top strategist
raillery Clinton thank you thank you
shed we're here in the spin room we're
going to take another break now we're
going to come back with more of our live
postgame debate coverage on Bloomberg TV
streaming on Twitter from Las Vegas
right after this
you
we're back we are wrapping up tonight's
Bloomberg politics / Twitter coverage of
tonight's third and final presidential
debate here at the University Veda in
Las Vegas mark there you see Hillary
Clinton Bill Clinton leaving finally
leaving the debate site the Clinton team
just heard from Joel Benenson before
they they feel good and I think it's
hard to fault her performance there may
be in some moments where she was evasive
but she was evasive in a deft way and
was pretty good at turning things away
but there'll be they'll be maybe half a
dozen or more cat topics where
Republicans will say she didn't address
the question I would like to return just
briefly to our interview with Michael
Flynn who I found like like perfectly
reflective of the confusion right now in
the Trump campaign about what to say
about what Donald Trump said on stage I
couldn't figure out what Michael Fleeman
was saying on one hand he was saying
well of course he'll accept the results
but after he checks to make sure they're
legitimate it was I thought
intellectually somewhat incoherent and I
think he's struggling to figure out how
that we've heard from a range of
Republicans here in the spin room our
colleagues reporting in Reince Priebus
chairman of the RNC Sean Spicer who
works with both they aren't seeing the
Trump key event but they're basically
saying is we're gonna win so this won't
be a problem or will accept the will of
the people but let's see what happens
you know let's see if they're any
improprieties but I think they're all
they're all taking a less hard-line
position than Trump stood took but try
not to repudiate what he said because
that's a little uncomfortable yes but
again it leaves open the question again
that we raised earlier which is what
does Donald Trump actually think about
this and I think he's made himself
pretty clear over the last week he
thinks the elections rigged and and he's
not ready to say that he's that he said
he's have faith in our democratic
institutions and will accept the outcome
so the question is what happens tomorrow
you know then what happens the day after
tomorrow is this question is going to be
begged and raised repeatedly to him and
the people around it more spinning is
going on here in the spin room both on
Donald Trump jr. and Eric Trump here in
the spin room giving their reaction but
let's go back outside to our Washington
bureau chief Megan Murphy for her final
thoughts Megan
I mean there's no question at this
moment of him saying he's going to keep
us in suspense about whether he's going
to accept the election results and also
his comments about women who've accused
him of unwanted sexual advances that
they want Fame and that part of the
Clinton campaign but I also want to
highlight another moment in this debate
there was a fairly extraordinary
exchange about Russia that will get a
bunch of attention in Europe and with
our allies abroad and his again
embracing Putin while saying he doesn't
know I'm praising him as a strong leader
and Hillary Clinton accusing him of
being Putin's puppet it was a real clash
it was it was a profound clash in terms
of how they both feel about foreign
policy and again Donald Trump with this
very extraordinary an ability to
distance cell from a regime that even
almost across his entire own party
including his own running mate
repeatedly denouncing Putin's strategy
policies etc and I think that in terms
of wider global impact of this debate
that will be another one of the moments
that people will pick out and examine
over the coming days mark thank you
Megan so much mark I have two quick
questions ask you one where do you think
things stand now with the relation to
WikiLeaks at this moment heading out of
this debate well I mean I think the
Trump campaign is going to give to you
to say over and over who really cares
where they came from they're in the
public domain now let's focus on the
content I think they're still struggling
I've asked a lot of Republicans today
which documents you want the American
people to focus on there's still a lot
right but nothing that really is going
to clearly break through right and I
think the Clintons are going to keep
saying the Russians the Russians write a
notably I thought Donald Trump when he
started saying things like Donald Trump
do your job but essa said horrible
things about you Bernie Sanders and
horrible things about you it was Vince
to certain kind of flailing not focusing
on one or two key documents that prove
something really damning the second
question I have for you is on the
question of Donald Trump and the women
who have accused him he dismissed them
out of hand tonight and basically said
all of them all of them are lying there
and when evaporated everything even
further and saying that this was done by
the Clinton campaign yeah so do you
think that that is now where do you feel
like that issue now stands as we head
into the last two and a half weeks of
the election you know no women have come
forward in the last couple days I think
if there are no more it will be a
lingering issue I think it's clearly
hurting with some voters but you're not
going to see very much news coverage
driven off but we're getting now at post
debate we just come
weeks ago a lot of coverage is going to
be about polls right a lot of coverage
is going to be about where the
candidates are spending money whether
Donald Trump still has a path to 200
some of the electoral right and
increasingly down ballot as we start to
focus on can Democrats win the Senate
can they even win the house how much is
their bleeding that's going on
if Trump remains close to double digits
behind Hillary takes it takes in the
last couple weeks an enormous
controversy to break through and become
the kind of dominant story we saw just
ten days ago with the release the excess
Hollywood tape yeah it'll be it's going
to be I don't I don't anticipate that
it's going to be a pretty two and a half
weeks but it was more more more crawling
around in the mud but I think we are now
finally at this moment we could say we
are headed into the genuine homestretch
which is both exciting and a bit of a
relief for Mark Halperin and me here in
the spin room at the University Nevada
Las Vegas we want to thank our friends
at Twitter who've been our exclusive
partners for this and all of the other
debate night coverages that we've done
be sure to town tune in to our show with
all due respect live at 5 p.m. Eastern
on Bloomberg TV and on Twitter where we
stream live now every day check that out
until tomorrow as I say from me and Mark
we say to you sign our on